hallo mein name ist luca ist treten nein
hier ist luca hettiger jetzt luca war
nicht witzig alles klar was wir spielen
heute das spiel ist dick dings irgendwie
ja wie heißt das eigentlich breaking die
bank das spielen wie heute und da ist
halt so ein spieler aus dieser stick
reihe
hier klicken einfach mal auf play
brauchst das laut wie das bei der serie
der spiele ja so üblich ist haben wir
wieder bestimmte sachen in dem ranking
war natürlich auch in der mikro aus all
das muss klappen wrecking ball ist
einfach die dümmste alternative vor
das sieht nicht gut aus ich wollte
irgendwie tanzen kommen dann nehmen wir
jetzt mal den teleporter damit hatten
wir bei der anderen serie immer glück
hier bin ich mir aber nicht sicher ob
das ganze letzte klasse sache mal andere
serie also anderes video wenn ihr das
noch nicht gesehen und flink ich euch
das hier da können wir drauf klicken da
könnt ihr euch das anschauen
das war wohl wenn diamanten geklaut
haben kommen wir nehmen einfach mal
laser drill
ich meine das ist doch jetzt auch was
was eigentlich
es funktioniert es funktioniert freute
es funktioniert das funktioniert das
funktioniert
alles klar da nehmen wir einfach mal das
absurdeste einfach bis geist als also
wir verkleiden uns als geldsack ach komm
wir haben es geschafft
ok alles klar freunde wir sind in der
bank drin dh wir sind in der bank drin
[Musik]
wieso ist das denn jetzt vorbei wie end
warum das uns wenigstens noch mal eben
die anderen sachen testen die wir da
noch zur auswahl hatten wir hatten ja
noch glaube ich explosionen da genau
explosionen können wir ihnen testen
wieso war das klar dass man hier aus wie
die letzte sache die wir haben jetzt
noch der tunnel das ist das ganze eine
schaufel und es kommt hinzu natürlich
kommen zu freunde wir haben alles
getestet
es geht nichts es geht tatsächlich
nichts bildet das jetzt de ist das jetzt
was soll das denn hält dieses spiel wird
man noch auf der website vorgeschlagen
und zwar dort was ist das was ist das
für ein schwachsinn was hier gerade an
was ist das für ein spiel das ist kein
spiel
das ist
[Musik]
der sinn dahinter jetzt sein soll
verstehe ich jetzt auch nicht so einfach
dem moonwalk ich glaube das meiste was
sich in diesem video gesagt habe war ich
verstehe es nicht ich dachte echt
liebesspiel was wir am anfang gespielt
haben hat mehr möglichkeiten des
hinweises hatte er weckt möglichkeit
aber alles falsch und ihm wird das den
ende der serie gebildet und jetzt
schauen wir uns so einen scheiß batman
steht an du mir leid dass sie ihre zeit
verschwenden das ende das war's es war
eine künstlerische meisterleistung des
[Musik]
komm halt dein maul die einzige seite
die ich wirklich mag im internet google
ja freuen das tut mir leid dass ich eure
zeit jetzt beansprucht habe ich dachte
echt da kommt mehr auf der erstmalig
dachte die zweite website wäre auch noch
ein spiel aber das heute war totales
fail video zum live wird versuchen da
gleich im schnitt noch ein bisschen was
rauszuholen das ist nicht ganz so
langweilig wird ich hoffe ich kriege das
irgendwie hin wenns euch doch gefallen
hat würde ich mich über eine bewertung
freuen und sonst schreibt mir noch in
die kommentare ob ihr fest woran das
liegt ob das wirklich dieses liegt das
mittlere serie ist ob ich jetzt gerade
außer sehen das ende aussehen gespielt
habe oder sowas
ich weiß es nicht wir sehen uns in den
nächsten video wieder